before the video starts guys i've come
together with muslim mate once again to
get to clean water
for families in gaza 105 pounds can
provide
interrupted water to two families for an
entire year give even if it's one pound
towards where did it guys get this stuff
from
forget that one thing we're certain
shaytan tries to stop you from praying
however when you have my prayer here
brothers and sisters and you open it
you give a big uppercut to shaytan you
know why because your tongue can't stop
you praying why
because for the new reavers or even
muslims who want to learn how to pray
one of the biggest obstacles when i
speak to them is
bro i don't know what to say and i say
brother what we're talking about the
scholars just say subhanallah
not anymore you know why brother sisters
oh what do we have here
so now guys it tells you what to do step
by step that to me is priceless and
amazing because when i have
new muslims and young muslims or persons
of any age who've come to me and want to
learn how to pray
i don't need to tell them to just say
subhanallah until they learn fatigue
fight is right in front of you now you
can read brothers and sisters
as you can see and do your salah no more
excuses
by one of these prayers brothers and
sisters as a gift to your loved ones who
want to get close to los angeles
or your reverb friends and let them
build a connection with their lord
oh oh how could i forget this where's
your mind out today let's open it
same prayer mat normally that brothers
and sisters they have a
booklet you're going to come out
inshallah bismillah there we go you've
got to say bismillah the way they don't
come out
brothers and sisters as you can see step
by step guide inshallah to praying their
salah
at a young age to build their
foundations is fundamental
and let me tell you something brothers
and sisters allah says in the quran it
is hateful in the
eyes of allah that you say something
that you don't do i'm getting one for my
daughter i'm not somebody who comes and
you get it you get me in there forget it
now
i'm getting one for my daughter and they
have brothers and sisters behind as you
can see
they have the app that look when you
point the camera these animations pop up
my gosh we've reached a new level with
these muslims brothers and sisters
and as you can see you've got the prayer
mat as well encourage
your kids to pray inshallah brothers and
sisters with this beautiful light let's
check this out inshallah
just like the ones for the other adults
brothers and sisters the same thing
applies here
with animation as you guys can see to
make it inshallah
friendly for the kids and teach them
step by step
how to pray their salah inshallah that
my friend is an investment that is
priceless for your kids
we know one of the forms of sadhaka is
what teaching something
to someone and you will benefit in your
graveyard imagine your young nephews
nieces or your own children
you get them one of these and they learn
how to pray and as you see them grow
older and older and older and they're
praying salah and you're like wow
i can remember the first time i imagined
them coming and saying uncle remember
the first time you bought me this prayer
man yeah
and he's praying ever since and you're
stuck stacking those deeds when you're
sleeping when you're eating when you're
drinking when you're in the bath
don't miss this opportunity buy one now
and change your life for the better
they've got very limited number of these
women sisters go to the description box
and the comment section inshallah and
get yours now straight away